>> Jesse: HE HAS A FIVE PAGE
PAGE --
>> Tyrus: THEY HAVE TO HUG IT
OUT.
I'VE BEEN WATCHING THIS FOR
YEARS.
YOU NEED TO HUG IT OUT.
>> Kimberly: FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST," FORMER
MAYOR RUDY GIULIANI SAYING HE IS
JOINING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LEGAL
TEAM IN AN EFFORT TO HELP
NEGOTIATE AND END TO THE MUELLER
PROBE.
THAT'S JUST IN FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
WHILE THE PRESIDENT ISN'T
CURRENTLY A TARGET IN THE COHEN
INVESTIGATION, HE COULD HAVE
SOME REASON TO WORRY BECAUSE
ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," ONE
OF MR. TRUMP'S LONGTIME LEGAL
ADVISORS JUST WARNED HIM COHEN
COULD TURN ON THE PRESIDENT IF
HE IS CHARGED.
KENNEDY.
>> Kennedy: TO JUAN'S POINT,
THERE BEEN SOME PROCEDURAL
INDICTMENTS.
THAT GOES TO SHOW YOU, IF YOU
CAST A BIG ENOUGH NET, YOU CAN
GRAB SOME FISH.
IN THE END, WHAT DOES THAT DO
FOR US?
DOES IT MAKE THE WORLD A MORE
JUST PLACE?
DOES IT HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE
OR DOES IT SHOW SHOW THAT IF YOU
GET ENOUGH WARRANTS AND YOU GO
THROUGH ENOUGH STUFF, YOU CAN
PRETTY MUCH TAG ANYONE WITH
ANYTHING.
>> Kimberly: 100%.
GREAT POINT FROM A LEGAL
PERSPECTIVE.
>> Juan: I DON'T SEE IT,
KENNEDY.
GO BACK TO WHAT JESSE WAS
TALKING ABOUT IN THIS MOST
RECENT CASE WHERE IT'S PORTRAYED
RECENT CASE WHERE IT'S PORTRAYE
PORTRAYED, THE FEDS KNOCKED DOWN
MICHAEL COHEN'S DOOR TO GET
THESE DOCUMENTS.
GUESS WHAT, YOU KNOW.
SEVERAL LAYERS OF GOVERNMENTAL
OFFICIALS AND JUDGES, MOST OF
THEM REPUBLICANS, HAD TO APPROVE
OF THIS.
IT WAS A LEGITIMATE EXECUTION OF
A WARRANT.
SO YOU HAVE TO KEEP THAT IN
MIND.
BUT GETTING BACK TO COHEN, TODAY
THE BIG NEWS ON COHEN IS I'M
SORRY.
I'M SORRY, BUZZFEED.
I AM SORRY I'VE BEEN THREATENING
TO SUE YOU.
SORRY, FUSION GPS.
NOT SUING YOU EITHER.
WE DON'T WANT ANY TROUBLE WITH
YOU, SAYS COHEN.
>> Jesse: HE PROBABLY IS
LOOKING AT IS BANK ACCOUNT AND
REALIZING HE CAN'T FOR THIS
LAWSUIT AGAINST BUZZFEED BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO COST AN ARM AND A
LEG AND HE'S PROBABLY UP TO HERE
IN LEGAL DEFENSE BILLS BEING
RAIDED IT.
IT'S MORE OF A MONETARY ISSUE,
LESS OF A FACTUAL ISSUE.
ON THE ROSENSTEIN THING,
ROSENSTEIN WAS THE ONE THAT DID
APPROVE THE RAID.
HE IS CONFLICTED.
HE IS THE ONE WHO WROTE THE MEMO
SAYING WHY COHEN SHOULD BE FIRED
-- WHY COMEY SHOULD BE FIRED.
NOW AN INVESTIGATION INTO
WHETHER TRUMP BROKE THE LAW
FIRING COMEY.
YOU DON'T SEE THAT AS A CONFLICT
YOU DON'T SEE THAT AS A CONFLIC
CONFLICT?
>> Juan: HE IS THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THAT'S HIS JOB.
>> Jesse: AND BROKE THE LAW.
>> Tyrus: EVERYONE KEEPS
TALKING ABOUT THE ADVICE HE WAS
GIVEN BY HIS ATTORNEY.
IF I HAVE EVER HAD AND ADVICE
FROM AN ATTORNEY, IT HAD GREAT
ADVICE.
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH COHEN'S
CHARACTER.
HE IS SAYING THIS IS WHAT YOU
NEED TO BE AWARE OF.
JUAN, YOU AND I ARE TIGHT.
IF YOU GET INDICTED, I'M NOT
GOING TO CALL YOU.
NO MATTER WHAT, I'M NOT GOING TO
DO IT.
DOESN'T MEAN THERE'S ANYTHING
THERE.
HE HAS HIS ATTORNEY.
HE'S DONE THINGS HE'S SUPPOSED
TO DO AS AN ATTORNEY, NOT ALL
THAT PRETTY.
SOME OF IT UGLY.
THAT'S HIS JOB.
HE TOOK ON THE RESPONSIBILITY.
THE PENALTIES FOR THAT.
HE'S A FIXER.
I WAS A FIXER FOR SNOOP.
>> Kimberly: GIULIANI AKIN TO
YOUR SITUATION?
>> Tyrus: GIULIANI IS A GREAT
PIT BULL.
I WOULD WANT HIM ON MY SIDE.
>> Kimberly: BREAKING NEWS
ABOUT GIULIANI.
>> Kennedy: IT DOESN'T
SURPRISE ME.
THIS IS PROBABLY A BETTER PLACE
FOR HIM THAN BEING
ATTORNEY GENERAL ARE HAVING SOME
OTHER FORMAL POSTNATAL
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE HE'S VERY
LOYAL TO THE PRESIDENT.
HE KNOWS THE LAW WELL.
HE'S BEEN THE U.S. ATTORNEY.
HE KNOWS HOW TO COMBAT A LOT OF
THE STUFF FROM THE INSIDE OUT
BUT IS ALSO A POLITICIAN.
AND HE'S A FIGHTER.
HE HAS REMAINED LOYAL TO THE
PRESIDENT EVEN THOUGH HE WASN'T
GIVEN ONE OF THE PLUM POSTS MANY
THOUGHT HE WOULD BE GIVEN.
>> Jesse: I THINK THEY WERE
WORRIED ABOUT HIM GOING THROUGH
THE NOMINATION PROCESS BECAUSE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT MIGHT
HAVE COME OUT.
NOW HE DOESN'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS.
I LIKE HOW THEY HAVE CROUCHED IT
-- COUCHED IT.
NEGOTIATING THE WINDING DOWN OF
THE DEAL.
HOW MANY MONTHS HAVE WE HEARD
THIS IS GOING TO END?
EVERY MONTH, WINDING DOWN,
WINDING DOWN.
HOPEFULLY THIS IS AN INDICATION
THAT PERHAPS THEY ARE
NEGOTIATING A WIND DOWN OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> Juan: PART OF THE STORY
TODAY IS THAT TRUMP CAN'T GET
MOST OF THE TOP-NOTCH
CONSERVATIVE LAWYERS IN AMERICA
TO COME WORK FOR HIM.
SO HE'S TALKING --
>> Jesse: HOW DARE YOU
BESMIRCH JAY SEKULOW?
>> Juan: JAY SEKULOW WAS
WORKING FOR HIM.
HE HAS LOTS OF TIES TO LOTS OF
PEOPLE, BEYOND DONALD TRUMP.
YOU GET RUDY GIULIANI, AND HE,
IN ADDITION TO BEING THE FORMER
MAYOR OF NEW YORK WAS A FORMER
PROSECUTOR, VERY SUCCESSFUL
PROSECUTOR.
HE HAS SOME INSIGHT THERE.
HE HAS BEEN OUT OF THE GAME FOR
A WHILE.
THAT'S NOT TO THE PRESIDENT'S
ADVANTAGE.
YOU NOTICE THE PRESIDENT WAS
CALLING A LOT OF HIS FORMER
LAWYERS.
JUST LAST WEEK THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" REPORTED
ONE OF THE FORMER LAWYER SAID GO
AHEAD, FIRE SOME OF THESE GUYS.
GET RID OF ROSENSTEIN.
DON'T BE BASHFUL.
DEVON REALLY DON'T TALK TO THE
INVESTIGATORS.
I THINK HE IS REACHING OUT TO
THE OLD GANG BECAUSE HE CAN'T
GET THE BEST OF THE CURRENT
CRIMINAL LAWYERS.
>> Kimberly: I THINK THAT'S A
FALSE STATEMENT.
HE LISTENS TO A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT OPINIONS AND
RUDY GIULIANI IS VERY WELL
RESPECTED.
I WOULD NOT SAY IN ANY WAY HE IS
OUT OF THE GAME AND NOT GOING TO
GIVE --
HE STILL WIELDS A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF INFLUENCE.
HE WAS AN OUTSTANDING PROSECUTOR
HE WAS AN OUTSTANDING PROSECUTO
I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE A VERY
WELL RECENT, MEASURED IN
ADDITION TO THE PRESIDENT'S
TEAM, ESPECIALLY AT THIS
JUNCTURE.
BRING IN SPECIALISTS AT CERTAIN
POINTS IN DIFFERENT PHASES.
JUST BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THAT THEY ARE WINDING THE
INVESTIGATION DOWN, IT DOESN'T
MEAN, AND THEY DIDN'T GET A
SMOKING GUN, THAT THEY ARE STILL
NOT GOING TO TRY TO GO AFTER THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Kennedy: A FORMER
PROSECUTOR AND POLITICIAN.
KNOWING THE LAW AND POLITICS IS
CRITICAL.
SO MUCH OF THIS, AND A LOT OF
THE PERCEPTION GOING INTO THE
MIDTERMS AND 2020 HINGES ON
THIS.
AND THE OUTCOME.
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
HAVE SOMEONE WHO CAN DO BOTH
THINGS ABLY.
>> Juan:
>> Tyrus: TRUMP IS A LOOSE
CANNON.
GETTING A LAWYER TO TELL THE
PRESIDENT WANT TO DO, HE IS
GOING TO REFER TO PEOPLE WHO
HAVE TOLD HIM WHAT TO DO IN THE
PAST.
AS A CLIENT, IT'S DIFFICULT.
YOU WILL SAY SOMETHING.
TWEET, SAY SOMETHING WRONG.
ATTORNEYS DON'T WANT THAT
HEADACHE.
THEY CAN REIN HIM IN.
WHERE IS GIULIANI, THEY KNOW HOW
TO DEAL WITH HIM.
MORE OF THAT AS OPPOSED TO WHY
WOULD YOU NOT WANT TO BE ON THE
FRONT END OF A FIGHT?
>> Kimberly: SOMETIMES YOU GO
BACK TO YOUR ROOTS.
YOU GO OLD SCHOOL.
>> Tyrus: YOU HAVE TO.